[Music]
in its of its news
oh yeah submitted by wine eyes why do I
like Asians yeah white ice no white
white why do I like this
oh I see like an anime character
instagram has announced a GTV a
standalone app for longer videos they're
basically coming for you YouTube yeah I
heard that did you post that like an
hour long yeah on Instagram it could be
a standalone app or through Instagram -
yeah so they're making this whole big
thing about vertical video we've been
preaching the other way yeah yes here we
go I'm not sure you guys a promo clip
for a GTV - ah
[Applause]
[Music]
boom
that's your friend
[Music]
with that the Brett man so funny so it
looks like this on it yep it's like what
snapchat was trying to do though or on
the Instagram app if you see this little
icon that's IG TV I saw they have shows
already in a lineup and they're shooting
the shows in this tall format yeah
that's interesting
Wow they're coming for YouTube this is
funny crazy we're trying to get people
more attached to their phones
yeah as it is are they or is anyone
allowed to make videos or is it like
they're just their shows red anyone can
upload their videos wow this is anyone
can upload videos but only a certain
like a select amount of people can
upload longer content oh this is the
movie theater let me see this because I
saw that is the phone really yeah that's
insane can you imagine if like we go
into the movie theater and everything's
pretty cool that'll be crazy I think
there's people that are already planning
to shoot this way so that even though
just tap into the vertical we're like
the Instagram takes up the full screen
but then they'll just still watch it
this way yeah well Instagram I mean
people are doing that already because I
was looking through the people I already
follow and there are people that are
just uploading their the content better
they already have yeah like what you're
saying the other way but Instagram is
just trying to make the whole vertical
thing I guess seen I said isn't that
what go 90 was trying to do like the
whole ago 90 was turn your phone 90
degrees yeah oh that's what go nanny was
about I heard it but I didn't know I
never knew it oh my oh that means
they're marketing suits in the paper it
does I think why people
anything you want to pay for extra yeah
so as of right now videos can be up to
ten minutes long but and eventually
it'll be up to like an hour long that's
pretty cool for now there is no
advertising being played but that's a
goal Instagram is smart Danna killin it
I like Twitter I like it but I don't
like it at the same time you like what
Twitter words you just gotta unfollow
all the negative people I love I love I
love the idea of it but I think like I'm
in a space now where it's like I see so
many people on their [ __ ] phones 24
[ __ ] 7 it's like holy [ __ ] man oh I
time my phone usage yeah people people
don't interact anymore like even like
the other day like I cuz I do that
morning walk you know man every kid
every [ __ ] kid but I'll [ __ ] fail
okay I'll walk like this oh yeah we go
to restaurants and entire families are
on their phones dude yeah I'm like yo
let's [ __ ] wild man do you mind
letting Issa just turned 16 and my
sister had a birthday party for her at
her house was everyone on their phone
talking yeah she's like he was the
weirdest [ __ ] ever she's like so you
know she had a little birthday party
I left them to whatever the [ __ ] they
wanted to do I go into the kitchen I go
get something and they're all sitting
around the dinner table just like this
and they're just laughing at each other
cuz they're texting each other instead
of talking oh I was just like she's like
this is [ __ ] weird like this
generations [ __ ] point you laughed
not text later what if they were talking
[ __ ] about her on the phone possibly
probably but she was just like it's so
weird it's so quiet like the whole time
and they were just older time it's been
like that for me is like if all of us
are like in you know on a trip or
something and we all took pictures and
now we're all trying to caption our
photos yeah like that makes sense but
then then like being at a party that's
the future of JK news we're gonna just
be recording here and then we're just
gonna she's gonna type in in this week's
[ __ ] news we got this and then I'm
just like oh [ __ ] that's crazy dawg
that's a conversation I love technology
I love YouTube all other stuff but
there's no such thing as time to place
anymore it's just it's always phone now
it's like oh [ __ ] man and that's why we
have like there's like like books being
written about dating on on through like
communication through this now you know
so this is what this ward mean this is
what this person means when they text
this is like holy [ __ ] yeah yeah just
talk to that person I want to touch a
titty not a phone okay I'm not sure if
you guys have it if you've met like a
couple of people who have watched our
stuff and you could tell if they've
never been outside you know they don't
they don't talk to people so when they
talk to you this is how they talk hey
man so I'm like a good fan stuff and my
[ __ ] eyes do you want a [ __ ] I
appreciate you so much to look at me and
like I met a couple of guys and you know
like you know I'm just curious I'll ask
them it's like amen so like what do you
do for fun II was all I stay at home
wasn't hmm I can't tell cuz you don't
you don't talk to people you don't
interact yeah these are the same people
to by the weight that number one they
can't get a [ __ ] job cuz they don't
know how to talk to [ __ ] people cuz
they're great on resumes but they're not
good at yeah human hey can I just say
though that each generation has their
version of phones like we're like FAQ of
the day was TV it's like all TV's
ruining heads and then it was video
games like all video games is ruining
kids before that was books yeah yeah
people were talking about on the trains
like people would just look at read
books all [ __ ] day and it's kind of
ruin society because no one's talking in
the Train right and and when I was
fifteen I was a moderator on an M&M
message board I think I've talked about
this before but I did not know how to
talk to people in real life I was so
funny and charismatic in the subject
yeah and we would have chat rooms and I
felt like those were my friends because
we make each other laugh and I was like
I could be who I really am there but for
some reason around other people I
couldn't it was hard myself that way and
so it was really really hard for me to
make eye contact it was hard for me to
flirt just within that what this this
thing that I'm talking about now is
we're still within that generation
yeah started with aim it started with
all that other [ __ ] too and it's just
gotten more severe since then I think
it's it's helping people build
confidence because in the past if you
didn't get to do that you would have
just stayed inside forever
yeah like it in you didn't you didn't
build social skills at all you had some
like what what the Internet has done is
given people that would have been you
know shy throughout their whole entire
lives a chance to become social online
and then slowly build those I like that
I like that part of it where like like
if you're too shy and person so you
start off with my DMS or comments and
you can like people's pictures and you
could communicate that way but I think
it sucks when that becomes the crush and
then now you meet someone in real life
and instead of communicating like a
human I'm still stuck to the phone yes I
wish there was a I wish there was a
meeting yeah it's good training wheels
but it shouldn't be that's still not
building a social skill that's like
saying because technology is so good now
that you can operate on this forever
whereas like when we were in high school
and all that it was it only took you so
far but then what I would do is like oh
I want to meet people that are into
breakdancing or whatever it in like I
didn't have friends that were there so
then I go on the forms mhm and then then
I could have like similar interest
people whereas like back then it's like
you couldn't find anyone in town you're
kind of like limited to the group of
friends when you use it as a way to meet
up with people in real life yeah that's
the medium part yeah that's the medium
to meet up with people but now when
people meet up they're on their phones
then I'm backwards I'd rather see and
talk to people face-to-face then like
anytime it's very extrovert uh yeah I
mean but now I feel like I'm turning
into an introvert because now I'm like I
don't want to meet new people but anyway
like whenever I talk to people on emails
or just on social media I'm always like
so self-conscious of what I'm writing
I'm like does this make sense is
grammatically right oh my god do I sound
stupid or do I sound like this or do I
come out like that
so I question like way more when I'm
doing it online than in person or others
because I'm an introvert like I actually
don't like you I don't I don't like
socializing I'm just really good at it
you know to me the same this is there's
a difference why do you think I go on
these walks alone I go by nice so I love
being alone yeah people always comment
on the ice to vlog and I'm hiking today
and I'm like hiking alone and the like
I'm going to the silver class and I'm
going alone everyone's like you always
go just [ __ ] alone
exactly I just never think about that
change
cuz in another episode you were like you
love people and he loves people like
isn't friends gran had family he loves
exactly the the definition of introvert
and extrovert is it's not one is a party
item or what yeah it's where you be
charged yeah so me I'm an extrovert
because I recharge with people I get
energy from people so Steve is yeah but
if they give me bad energy I recharge
negative energy like charge their energy
up right so then so for me it's like I
like groups I like things because I
can't be isolated mm-hmm is it makes me
feel drained yeah that's how Steve is
yeah but if you're introvert that means
you need a loan time to charge up I love
talking to people but it drains my whole
battery and then I made a day alone of
just like so if you go to crowds if you
go with people and you feel drained
afterwards then your introvert but me I
do meet and greets I do that stuff and
yeah that's how serious you love talking
to people when I go like for example
like a couple of homies are like yo I'm
coming to LA right like we're going to
go out cool that I need be by myself
like three days yeah have my own [ __ ]
and then I'll be ready to hang out with
you we can go to an open house and it's
just a [ __ ] real estate agent yeah
he's showing me a dope ass house buddy
[ __ ] drain the [ __ ] because I for
me when I meet strangers and I'm trying
to like talk to people I don't know I
feel drained but then when I'm around
you guys like my friends my family of
people that I really care about that's
when I get really energized going I'm
alone I'm really depressed but yeah so
you're an extrovert or expert because
you're taking on strangers og and that's
that's why it's draining cuz they're
maybe not the best energy service
[ __ ] and weirdos are draining no
matter what if you're introvert
extrovert doesn't matter yeah but it
also might be you being self-conscious a
stranger that's draining your energy to
maybe I'm very self conscious but if you
need to recharge with others like that
that's definitely a extrovert tree if
you you know that's the that's the pure
definition if you're alone and you start
to feel recharged then you're introvert
yes Steve it gets like that when I bring
him to like some beauty event or
whatever he's like I hate this is so
draining but he loves being around
people that like he likes that he loves
and that's
recharges
[Music]